[Music]
[Applause]
pharming Critic we didn't get much sleep
- excited for your bowl of Lucky frosted
cocoa Trix it's part of a complete
breakfast
from where Dairy Queens the dumpster now
don't be like that I poured you each a
bowl event last Saturday in preparation
for this you mean this has been out for
a week this helps open up the flavors I
had a big dinner and I'm vegetarian I'm
pretty sure that used to be alive well
suit yourself okay critic can you
explain why we're up at dick o'clock in
the morning I forgot your humble aid you
know where of the ritual of fairy
morning you see Saturday morning used to
be a special time for kids we'd often
have friends leave over the night before
and then wake up to the majesty of
television Saturday morning cartoons
each one filled with brain rotting
material coaxing us to buy teeth rotting
material
unfortunately TV did its job too well
and the following generation said let's
just have this raise our kids 24/7
Plus every second of every goddamn day
was already morning cartoons and they
got rid of them years later society
sucks okay we're not 10 years old we had
Saturday morning cartoons too
we're just wondering why we're here this
Saturday oh well that's because we're
hang on my's don't want the best in
Saturday morning awesomeness Fox kids in
1992 then still young Fox Network air
did Saturday morning lineup of shows
called Fox kids
it included bumpers PSAs catchy songs
and of course some of the best kids
shows to ever air on TV
eventually branching out to Monday
through Friday as well Fox kids lasted
12 years an unbelievable run when you
consider its counterpart the Disney
Afternoon lasted only seven years while
half of these shows can still be viewed
today some of them have sadly never
gotten the DVD release or were never
aired again so keep in mind we're not
going to look at every single show that
aired on Fox kids because like I said
this is 12 years of material which
gonna look at the most unique inspired
and memorable parts of the greatest
Saturday morning lineup there was so
with our sugar-coated poison in hand
younger kids wanting to watch what the
older kids are watching hey guys we
watch the shows too and an
overprotective parental who thinks if
it's not Sesame Street it's bad for them
I'm sorry but you're too young to see
this kind of stuff
I'm older than half of them over there
shoo shoo
you're not even a real father kids are
you enjoying Saturday morning yes that's
good
I'm gonna go make some waffles on the
stove just for you do we have a stove
well figure out how that happened later
this is Fox kids
[Music]
the Tiny Toons in the Hannibal happy
duck with his own
[Music]
a superhero
nobs Diddy
everybody
it's my boss let's start with one of
their earliest staples Bobby's world oh
I've seen this it's like if Calvin and
Hobbes were made by Ned Flanders hey
it's a lot more than that that's pretty
okay it's pretty accurate Bobby's world
was based off of a little boy boys that
comedian Howie Mandel did for his
popular stand-up
and because the 90s were a strange time
where crude comedians got kid-friendly
shows he was given one of his own just
look at how awkward he is in the
live-action openings hi everyone I'm
Howie welcome to Bobby's world so then
you know what I really hate
of course you don't because you don't
know me you know what I hid germs
god I hate germs well certainly aimed at
a younger demographic than the other Fox
kids shows Bobby's World Showcase the
imagination of a little boy
misinterpreting what adults say either
bad or he swallowed off his mother's
nyquil either wait neat the characters
included how he has his father with the
jew-fro rat tail haircut common the cast
of Fargo is his mother then you need to
go upstairs and wash your face and hands
before we leave her out roast on Channel
his older brother representing the 90s
trying to kill the 80s and his older
sister representing the 80s refusing to
die along with uncle Ted to give us a
blanket or a fart joke let's just keep
that our little secret okay Bobby had
children's fantasies often based on
movies a kid his age when see yet
looks like somebody Fred the
kid-friendly version of die hard
so was it any good it was hypnotizing
Lee unoffensive it's for little kids so
it's simple but imaginative it even had
possibly the first Saturday morning
character to get pregnant and we
actually see her progression throughout
the season little touches like that make
it stand out just enough and I guess
kids thought the same thing because it
was surprisingly one of Fox's
longest-running shows at akechi as hell
theme song and you have a decent start
to the Fox Kids lineup
that's cool and all but how about some
more violent stuff well you're in luck
as this network also had Tom and Jerry's
kids
I retract that yet talking about the Tom
[Music]
yeah another strange trend and kid shows
for a while was just making famous
characters younger because if there's
anything better than seeing someone
brutally dismembered and maimed it's
seeing it happen to them as children
finally somebody gets it I have issues
it was pretty much the same thing as the
regular Tom and Jerry cartoons except it
was done with kids so the slapstick
wasn't nearly as violent and therefore
not nearly as funny granted had had
other characters too like spike and his
son tyke droopy and his son triple in
fact Howard Tom and Cherie younger if
their counterparts are the same age and
how is guy fall prequel if M is in
Goldeneye also how minions exist with
dinosaurs millions of years ago this is
a road you don't want to go down
okay never bring it up again
much like Bobby's world this was
obviously meant for smaller children so
it was tamer and more gentle than
previous versions so not good
yeah but for little kids it gets the job
done I guess I mean it is better than
other outings Tom and Jerry have had
recently lasted a few seasons though so
it obviously had its fans it's not the
kid Mouse team we remember but it's not
obnoxious either it wasn't harmful
enough to be Tom and Jerry but it was
harmless enough to be a decent
distraction for little kids
[Music]
well let's get to something more grisly
an adult Peter Pan and the Pirates let
me explain we all know the classic book
play Disney film and childhood scarring
but few adaptations of Peter Pan ever
captured the darker and surprisingly
more adult take of the original JM
Barrie's story than this one I know that
sounds strange but this was actually a
really great show
they were ideas that took concepts from
the original book and pushed them even
further for example Peter steals the
Pirates shadows and what happens they
walk upside down because they've lost
their anchor to the ground
that's so creatively strange but it
weirdly makes sense in another episode
peter has gone for too long if it gets
about everybody because he's distracted
by Wendy's future daughter in the real
world who he brings back to Neverland to
meet her future mother despite them
being roughly the same age it's super
surreal but it's also surprisingly adult
it's kinda like the ending of return to
Neverland where young Peter meets older
Wendy that's a lot of people's favorite
part of that movie and this show is
mostly comprised of scenes like that the
characters all have fleshed out
personalities with Peter always hungry
for mischief The Lost Boys and pirates
all having distinct character traits and
in my opinion the best Captain Hook ever
portrayed played by the only actor who
could perfectly portray him literally
the first perfect thought that comes
into your head is who plays mmm Curt
you've got the right tempo if I must die
I will encounter darkness as a bride and
hug it in my arms this is the first
Captain Hook that has dimension to it
yes he's an angry screamer and a
scoundrel but he prides himself on being
a gentleman and a sophisticate one
minute he's ready to stab your heart but
the next he might let you go if you make
him laugh with a reading of Shakespeare
Oh God they give you death by inches and
those expensive thanks that
to witness this atrocity he was an
egotist but still valued his bizarre
ethics it made him both funny and
intimidating at the exact same time and
nowhere is the series complexities shown
best than in its series finale where
Peter decides he does want to grow up
and he starts to wither away into an old
man unaware that he's actually taking
Neverland with him so you could argue
hook was being portrayed even before
hook was doing it it surprisingly
intends an unbelievably well done it
lasted for only one season but it
resulted in a ton of episodes and had a
pretty good life in reruns criminally
though there is no DVD release of it if
you're able to find it on YouTube or
anywhere else
definitely watch as many of them as you
can it's a cannon ball of imagination
waiting for you
[Music]
that's all fine and good but what about
the poor people who demand a series
about demonic fruit
I had no segue into the show so um
because we apparently demanded it attack
of the killer tomatoes was given its own
cartoon series based on the b-movie
comedies it did have some of the
original characters like Igor Tara that
parachute guy and even John asked him
for prising his role as the mad
scientist who made the evil vegetables
fruit
it's 2018 nobody uses that term anymore
it certainly had the strangeness of the
film's down but it didn't have much more
beyond that the plot is similar to the
movies and that a mad scientist wants to
take over the world with the tomatoes
and his failed experiments Tara nft and
tomato War veteran Wilbur tries to stop
he gets help from the main lead a boy
who was not in the movies and you can
clearly see why he's pretty bland and
forgettable and the animation doesn't do
him or any of the other characters any
favours you know you're supposed to stay
away from salt if someone sees you what
is this this girl is the binary code on
her neck being hacked mass blackmail
george clooney with return of the killer
tomatoes footage yeah okay look at this
scene she have to lean over to talk to
ft but look how she does it it's this
part the joke or is it just poorly
animated the whole show is kind of like
this leaving you with no idea what's
intentional and what isn't even the
dialogue you can't figure out what
they're aware of and what they're not
[Music]
whatever you're thinking erase it from
your heads I had a line about her being
saucy but never mind I guess on a level
bizarre awkwardness I can see this
entertaining a few but for many kids the
most memorable part of the show is the
theme song but goddamn that's a catchy
theme song
[Music]
but not all the Fox kid shows started
off on Fox kid a charming story about a
dead man who befriends an underage girl
he was going to marry finally somebody
who gets it do I have to worry about you
you might Beetlejuice had only the
slightest connection to the movie which
was surprisingly welcomed as it allow
for a lot of wild and inventive designs
granted in the movie everyone looks the
way they do because they died that way
here I don't know how this they
were supposed to die to look like this
Tim Burton himself helped design the
show and it certainly shows and all the
strange people and creatures it had
little in terms of plot but it had a lot
in terms of visual and gross-out humor
at the time especially when there wasn't
much in terms of dark or McCobb cartoons
this one gave us a small but still
memorable taste of the enjoyably morbid
as a waste of time it was a fun
but I know what you're thinking if
people just got a cartoon why not Little
Shop of Horrors because no one was
thinking that just for that the plan
traps little shop is based on the
musical interpretation about the
man-eating plant except Seymour is now a
little boy the plant raps instead of
sings and absolutely none of it looks
completed this looks more like the
bumpers you see before they go to
commercial you don't get those bumpers
enough credit the focus of the show is
the plant is trying to get Seymour to
win the girl and defeat the bully while
also running a plant shop that's
constantly infested with their musical
numbers have the original cinematic
ending
why is he in shock the plant is talking
the flowers act as backup singers all
the time
I'm sure the plant is talking his lips
move so rarely computer training many
part o edible I guess I can give credit
that for a show that had a budget of
monkey feces the backgrounds are at
least creatively simple I mean I'm sure
the layout artist had two minutes to
color these on Mario Paint but there is
at least a little structure in between
the poorly animated sections of God he's
having a stroke nope that's just a bad
show the writing doesn't make any sense
either
the girl on the show is obsessed with a
refrigerator I'm going to repeat that
the girl in the show is obsessed with a
refrigerator and they never explain why
it's the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen I think it's really cool women hey
my love of refrigerators has nothing to
do with my gender now if you'll excuse
me
[Music]
clearly Little Shop of Horrors was ahead
of its time like I said this has a
little redeeming value but I'm sorry I
have to reference a little shop of
horrors our toon show in the 90s where
the plant wraps I know you think it's a
crime it exists but it's an even bigger
crime to act like it doesn't exist the
show lasted only 13 episodes before it
was yanked and you can see why this
fertilizer didn't get far I'm noticing a
pattern of characters that most likely
wouldn't make it a show not making a
good show
were there any existing characters that
allowed for clever writing or
intelligent dialogue yes really
Warner Brothers was given the task of
turning one of their most profitable
Looney Tunes the Tasmanian devil into a
hit show how do you do that though when
his dialogue is mostly well they
ingeniously make everyone else very well
spoken even to the point of it being
ridiculously overwritten up Julie let
aportfolio start with an egg yolk no
less than 36 percent per annum there's
nothing like a paper in a recliner craft
chair for a man after a tough day of
doing whatever it is I do for a living
to rekindle the lost flame that connects
ourselves with the true harmony of the
universe now I am in a quandary
technologies the culprit fear science be
blamed because of this not only to
Tasmania have a distinct sense of humor
but its writing was surprisingly ahead
of its time along with other shows like
duck man and Simpsons yes really based
in the land down under where Wakko
Warner sings the theme song Tess lives
with this talkative family interacting
with his talkative friends and partaking
in the conversations as little as
possible much like the other Warner
Brothers shows there's a lot of fourth
wall breaking a lot of slapstick and
like I said surprisingly a lot of
talking again from a show where the main
character talks like this Wow I'm not
talked about by many Tasmania still had
an impressive four-year run it had good
animation good timing and actors who had
to talk a surprising mouthful for a show
about a Tasmanian devil ferociously
intense
not likely to make much progress given
if choice of methodology got a house to
show career seminar to attend some
charity work to do in a dinner party to
prepare tell my schedule is pretty much
open it's so strange this would be both
as funny and as worthy as it is but
maybe that's part of a bigger joke in
general that the most dialogue focused
slapstick children's show was around
this guy
shall we pause to consider this irony
maybe later
sadly there's only a few DVD releases of
this show it honestly deserves a lot
more the episodes you can find though
are a ton of laughs and had a lot more
work put into them than they probably
deserved to put it short Tasmania is a
heck of a spin watching Tiny Toons here
at Nickelodeon very innocent wholesome
quality Tiny Toons is up next
but what did that have to do with it
because that's II know we spa for me it
wasn't a Nickelodeon it was on Fox kids
and they didn't do stuff like sing the
wheels on the bus go round and round
ahead good riding it was a good show
shame on you - shame on you oh my god
okay I'm sorry I just I never had outlet
to talk about that clip it always bother
me it always fight the castle make
things wrong about that clip it was a
good decent show it just has been
building for a while it's critic it's
not your fault
I know it's not your fault I know it's
not your fault don't do this to me man
it's not your fault don't do this to me
man not you not your man suits so having
a very successful run in syndication Fox
kids bought Tiny Toons and ran it from
its third season odd it was one of the
few shows based on the younger version
of popular characters that branched out
not only to be successful and funny but
also obtain its own identity over time
characters like Elmyra Montana Max and
furball were all very different from
their counterparts Elmer Yosemite Sam
and Sylvester the nice thing is while in
syndication there was definitely a lean
towards being more kid-friendly but when
it went to Fox they broke out more of
the classic Looney Tunes humour with
celebrity jokes in joke satire of Buster
that sounded eerily
close to the Cryptkeeper it played well
so well that one of the most popular
characters plucky duck was given his own
show that same year yeah so what was
that it's complicated
you see the first episode of the
spin-off was actually hilarious they're
acknowledging he's getting his own show
but he abandons it to try and beat
Batman in Tim Burton's next movie
it's amazing how funny it is the
violence of the satire the celebrity in
jokes it had a ton of viewers rolling on
the floor with laughter it was so good
that sounds great what happened that was
the only new episode
they weirdly just start showing clips
from other Tiny Toons episodes where
plucky duck was the focus so what was
supposed to be the plucky duck show just
became the best of plucky duck a cliff
show maybe this was filler for a show
they didn't make in time maybe the only
enemy of the pilot but pulled the plug
like what they did with the Oh Myra show
whatever they did it faded quickly
resulting in only 13 episodes regardless
we still got a pretty funny first
episode and a ton of great material from
the original Tiny Toons giving it a
memorable and hilarious run but not
every show gets the attention it
deserves I know you mean
[Music]
that masterful work will have its day
but I was talking about eco cap in a
world filled with Ren & Stimpy
knock-offs
eek the cat was arguably one of the
first but just like those other shows it
had a similar style but still its own
hilarious identity the opening sums it
up perfectly he has a dream about
helping someone wakes up to reality and
everything tries to kill him that's
basically the plot of every episode the
world is trying to punish him for all
the good deeds he does but nevertheless
he is always kind and optimistic always
helping people no matter what's thrown
at him they never hurt help and indeed a
lot of strange things are thrown at him
it's a world where snacks can blow up in
your head
cuddly bears are greeted with machine
guns and Ross Perot was commander in
chief back when that was the craziest
person who could be President there was
a mean-spirited creativity to it that
was held together by just how gentle and
helping each is hey you know swimming
for an hour after you eat you don't want
to get a crab no matter what he always
wanted to help even if it meant getting
pummeled well at least the beautiful
planet of Earth has been spared and
those bad aliens will never do such bad
things again and someone will be here to
get me soon and I'm just sure of it
helmet because curse word he ever used
was kumbaya Granta is the show went on
they seem to run out of ideas so they
started putting him in several movie
parodies they were fine I guess but it
was a little odd even for this show to
make things even stranger the timeslot
was suddenly being shared with another
show suddenly it was called extravaganza
and half the running time was dedicated
to thunderlizards a series about
dinosaurs who were trying to wipe out a
new species called man at the moment
there's only two of them and they're
constantly screwing up trying to evolve
these guys are like the
to tie for SpongeBob and Squidward
except the sexual tension might be a
little greater with them the show was
pretty funny but not as good as eek
nobody minded too much that the shows
were cut in half as we still got our
daily dose of strange and the show had a
good run of five seasons
sadly again though there's no DVD
release hence the watermark with the
rise of even more surreal humor and
internet culture this really should be
more available to the public it was mean
violent cruel relentless yet funny
enough had a good heart at the center of
it it definitely needs to make a
comeback and hopefully somebody out
there can make it happen in the future
but their stuff Rick dog lovers - Jim
Henson's dog city for example lasted for
three seasons based on Henson's short
film from another TV series the show
opened in the puppet world where an
animator created a private eye show
about detective named ace heart and then
jumps into animation as ace constantly
battles the gangster Bugsy vile with the
help of chief rosio gravy and paper puff
named Eddie as you'd imagine there's a
lot of dog funds in this which is
usually annoying but after a while
there's so many of them you're kind of
floored somebody could exist I did some
sniffing around trying to get a leg up
in the case outlaw brand beef biscuits
are not simple not that much buck but
what about a bike station Wi-Fi deal
somebody says one table scrap short of a
full doggy bag I'm annoyingly intrigued
like many Jim Henson projects there's a
charm in how cube friendly it wants to
be
for example the animator hates violence
of guns are usually replaced with
rolled-up newspapers and when guns do
eventually make their way in he switches
it out for a senseless showdown it's
kind of adorable since this is running
with scissors the strange thing is Fox
would do another dog detective show
called droopy master detective they have
the same obsession Disney Afternoon had
over docks did they just think this
would be the next big thing
did they even watch this show while
jumpy was cam pretty quickly dog City
had a pretty decent run so I guess if
you're a dog detective person I'm a cat
detective person lies
dog city is cute enough to give a
viewing you know critic I gotta admit
these shows are fine but they're not
really mind blowing yeah where's the
really cool stuff well over the next
three years fox kids would have their
highlights they would give us the most
incredible awesome badass shows any kids
ever seen at the time
dad stop putting in I'm just trying to
help
you're embarrassing me in front of my
friends go away okay I love you son
Victor I didn't quite hear that drum I
can't hear you I love you too stop stop
[Applause]
so even though Fox Kids was growing it
still wasn't the dominant force in
Saturday morning or kid shows but year
three is when all of that started to
change Fox Kids expanded from Saturday
morning to weekday afternoons which was
a risky and expensive move if they
wanted kids to constantly be watching
they needed some kick-ass shows to keep
them heart thankfully they had little
gems like this this and now I've talked
to death about these shows in the past
so I'll do my best to talk about
something different about the impact
that they had first Batman the Animated
Series after two wonderfully dark Batman
movies an animated version of The Dark
Knight not only won both kids and adults
over but it served as a game-changer for
Batman in general a lot of writers went
on to several other Batman Canon
projects several characters and back
stories created for the show made their
way to the official Batman lore and even
to this day when most people read Batman
comics the voices that pop in their
heads are always Kevin Conroy as Batman
and Mark Hamill as the Joker it's hard
to read them without making that
connection wherever you go I'll be right
behind you unlike other kid shows at the
time Batman took years to develop
resulting in a unique style not often
seen in many animated series the
backgrounds always started off on black
paper to keep the dark environment of
the show consistent the characters and
buildings had an art deco style as
opposed to a pulp comic style like all
the other shows and the atmosphere in
general was more adult allowing for
quieter moments slower pacing and more
realistic acting there was no other
animated action series that looked like
this at the time and now every animated
action series is trying to look like
this it walked the perfect tightrope
between two playful and funny and too
dark and gritty it seemed like it
incorporated everything it felt true to
the comic roots worked in the adult side
of the movies had a good laugh at the
camp eNOS of the situation's and yet
somehow also felt like its own unique
vision it's just as good today as it was
when it first premiered and no other
Batman show has ever topped it think
about it after all these years and all
the other incarnations they have come
out no other show has done Batman as
well it's just as clear today as it was
a years ago why this
was a huge game-changer but Warner
Brothers was breaking new ground with
another game-changer just talking about
Animaniacs I see you guys think I've
talked about too much huh
if Animaniacs was a prostitute you'd
have paid off five of our house loans
yeah what did they save your cat or
something no but through the magic of
wishful delusions now they have ah fine
fine I'll keep it short
see missed the follow-up to Tiny Toons
Animaniacs was a variety show that
stepped up its game every episode had a
plethora of great songs memorable
characters hilarious animation but most
important of all brilliant writing it
was truly the closest we ever came to
experience the fresh comedy of the
original Looney Tunes they had the great
comebacks the violent slapstick the
imaginative take on the world we all
wanted to experience this must have been
similar to when people saw Bugs Bunny
cartoon for the first time on the big
screen there's just an excitement that
you were gonna see something clever
funny and filled with so much energy
they felt alive along with Batman in
Tiny Toons it was one of the few shows
that had an entire orchestra providing
the music and speaking of which the
brilliant songs are still being used by
kids today to pass countless school
exams in fact they even keep updating
the songs to coincide with the
constantly changing world
in fact these songs even won on tour
with songwriter Randy Raquel and actor
Rob Paulsen singing they're infectious
ear worms they're still that popular
it seems the show was so popular that's
even being rebooted
in 2020 these characters are coming back
to give their take a modern-day insanity
imagining the shots they can take with
the internet trends politics
it's crazy exciting to see where this
can go will it be as good as the
original I guess only time will tell
but one thing's for sure we'll always
have these timeless classic hilarious
characters to look back on
[Music]
[Applause]
now on to a show I know I've barely
talked about x-men will you two knock it
off knock it off you've talked about
this show so many times there's nothing
left to cover oh yeah I bet I can find
something new to talk about prove it
fine apparently was the passion project
of the head of Fox Kids
Margaret loesch ironically used to be
the head of Marvel television producing
hit after hit except in one category
funny enough the Marvel characters never
caught on in TV every attempt seemed to
bomb including an early version of x-men
where Wolverine was Australian white
she's known in the x-men gee she's just
a kid that's almost too ironic
she went from Studio to studio trying to
get x-men made but they all said the
same thing it was too adult and nobody
would watch it Margaret then went on to
be the president of Fox kids and cared
so passionately about getting x-men a TV
series that she put her job on the line
they knew if this was gonna be good a
lot of money had to be thrown at it so
she took the gamble but picked the right
producers writers and actors to make it
work the only downside is there was not
much time to make it work in fact the
tone and animation were so campy and
off-key in the first season that they
only had two episodes for the big
October premiere that being the two-part
pilot what the hell do you do when he
need months and months to rework your
show you present the first two episodes
as a preview yeah pissed off the
advertisers and caused a fortune but
Margaret and showrunner Eric Lee Walt
knew they had to get this right if they
were gonna have a hit the preview
thankfully went over incredibly well and
left people wanting more so after a redo
of the show with better animation and
more adult atmosphere it finally
premiered with no other new shows being
put on that's right because they waited
until spring it got more attention
because everything else was reruns as
you'd imagine the numbers were through
the roof x-men was suddenly Fox's
biggest hit it represented more than
cool heroes with powers it grasped the
prejudice and torture character arcs as
well as the all-around badass nature
people loved from the comics after being
told no over and over from several
studios and even ignoring advice from
stainle to make
more kid-friendly the creator stuck to
their guns and turned in a huge payday
much like the x-men who had to fight for
human dignity so did the creators who
wanted to see their timeless characters
done right x-men would go on for five
seasons one of Marvel's longest-running
series it launched them into the
mainstream more than before leading to
several reboot series comics spin-offs
and of course a beautifully inconsistent
movie franchise this was a gamble that
paid off all the way to the X Bank so
with those three gigantic hits Fox Kids
was moving on to their next big game
aren't you forgetting another hit show
don't think so yeah yeah one that still
makes like a butt ton of money even
today there's no other hit shows at that
time mm fine there might have been
another teeny incy wincy hit of a show
called Mighty Morphin Power Ranger
he's no secret I never got into this
show even as a kid it was just so dumb
the same time Batman and x-men were on
we had about that double date we talked
about yeah so dumb but okay let's talk
about a bit because on the one hand it
is a brilliant marketing strategy five
teenagers with attitude
our summoned by job of a fuzzy mouth to
stop a space witch named Rita for her
crimes of bad lip-syncing they first do
a martial arts fight against a monster
of the week and then they grow in size
and use giant robots in a fight against
Los Angeles Japanese mountains
so yeah the set up was pretty obvious
shoot American actors for dirt cheap and
then cut the Japanese stock footage from
another hit show in Japan Power Rangers
of course turned into a huge hit which
meant as long as they were still making
shows in Japan yeah they'll never stop
they could keep making shows here Power
Rangers was not only the longest-running
series on Fox kids but it surpassed it
even after Fox kids shut down the show
still continues to have an impressively
long lasting life it had many spin-off
storylines reunions callbacks and tons
of b-movie monsters to fight on the one
hand I really wanted to like this show
because hey martial-arts giant robots
killer monsters that can be some fun
but flipped over me so dumb
it was clearly past my time and not for
me but that doesn't mean they didn't tap
into something that excited a ton
of kids and some very disturbed adults
years later Power Rangers whether you
like it or not was and still is an
impressive spectacle
but it wouldn't be the 90s unless we
forcibly had to teach you
[Music]
thankfully some shows were better at it
than others
like where on earth is Carmen Sandiego
nope this was a different kind of Carmen
Sandiego one that was on a kids computer
game that tried to educate you that's
exactly what Carmen Sandiego is okay
maybe not that different
van spring player always had to pick two
characters to go after Carmen and he
always picked the sister and brother duo
ivy and Zac Oh God tell me he didn't
ship them it's a kid who's always at his
computer so problem probably hello
player thanks for picking me
yeah that sounds weird there's a freaky
ass chief who seemed to be a mix between
Max Headroom and the genie IV IV IV you
simply must learn to accessorize
regrettably so and the duo had to chase
Carmen around the world to give back the
famous monuments that they'll inevitably
homeschool us about shoes you'll be
heading son Colin it's the home of
wooden shoes tulips and the world-famous
windmills this doesn't work as well as
the game show because the investment
came from having to know the information
to get further here the show just kind
of comes to a halt to teach you
something
he used bold colors and violent
brushstrokes often slashing at the
canvas as he paid it higher hand though
it did have a story to each one and
Carmen herself was just as stylish and
cool a villain as you would want her to
be in fact a lot of the time she would
leave the clues on purpose because she
loved the thrill of the chase at first I
thought this was kind of lame but then
the more I thought about it is Carmen
and the other versions to always leave
something behind here she's at least
owning up to her stupidity the show
lasted a good while with four seasons
and even though the education stuff did
feel a little forced it was still cool
saying the queen of Thieves do what she
does I guess help us get a little
smarter watching it too it was decent
enough for what it was
[Music]
hey kids what's more awkward than movie
spider-man other movie spider-man and
cartoon spider-man and other cartoon
spider-man
[Music]
writing the tales of x-men heck even
doing a crossover with them later
spider-man try capturing the same
complex characters and ideas their other
hit Marvel show had did they it's
complicated enough spider-man was great
if you wanted the experience of the
comic but it didn't really save way into
an emotional TV series it might have
been surprisingly over-ambitious as
every second it's either explaining
what's going on explaining the emotions
explaining the inner monologue it could
never take a break then we have to
assemble those of us who are left and go
protect the site of the Doomsday complex
if you like and witnessing a part of
this country's history after seeing the
beacon
we always assembled here to remember
where this building was have you been
meddling oh my god breathe you guys are
going faster than the dialog in the
social network the CG city wasn't a bad
idea at the time but now it just sticks
out like a sore thumb in other instances
the CG background matches the look of
the painted background this just looks
like he's swinging into a screen saver
but those are just little details maybe
it could still work if the writing was
sharp anyway this lizard thing is
probably just an urban myth wait a
minute
looks like I was mistaken but again to
its credit it did take a lot from the
comics trying to cram in as much as you
can in a kid show I just think it did a
- damn much it wasn't Power Ranger silly
but it wasn't x-men serious either it
was something in between but it seemed
to be enough as this Marvel show lasted
five seasons so I guess it must have
made a big connection with a lot of fans
granter there were some really cool
things to see like Tony J is the kingpin
Mark Hamill is the Hobgoblin not Topher
Grace is venom and to think we thought
this would be the greatest Marvel
team-up we would ever see on any screen
power of web-shooters get real sticky
sure these days it sounds a little corny
looking back it's not as bad as I
remember but it spacing is too way too
fast for us to absorb every adventure
it's got his fans though and I can see
why it was a huge hint and anything that
makes this a little less awkward must be
doing something right but for my money
the best superheroes always shouted oh
can I say it I always wanted to say good
Fork
it was one word there's one goddamn
where with five words you can't even say
five lies this is nice well the word
comedic takes on superheroes in the past
none we're quite as funny or odd as the
tick again leaning is writing towards
the adults rather than kids the tick
told the story of an eye invulnerable
absent-minded superhero and his voice of
reason psychic Arthur you can't fight
evil with a macaroni duck I won't be the
judge of that
well the idea based on the cult comic
went through several different
incarnations in the future most people
agreed this is the one that was the most
faithful to the source they did what
many superhero parodies do adding a big
slice of reality to our comic book
fantasy but the biggest punch at
lampooned is just how many damn
superheroes there are particularly now
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
tick address what would happen if so
many of these side characters and
spin-offs really did exist in the same
universe this is all the heroes you
could find well it's such short notice
these people have lives too you know
well sometimes the animation could be a
little choppy in the timing a hint off
the tick still had original writing with
very enthusiastic characters but what
really pursued us where were we really
trapped come on Arthur
matha with me tick himself it's
infectiously positive
he just loves being the hero but he
never came across as egotistical he
really believes his corny speeches and
one-liners thinking they inspire people
just as much as they inspire him
what pursued us we're our own obsessions
I'm good
you're evil I'm a woman you're a man
what does it all mean nothing he never
felt cynical or mean-spirited he doesn't
think much about what he's saying but
rather the way he's saying it to a point
where even silverware can serve as a
battle cry it had a modest run of three
seasons and continue to run in
syndication only increasing its cult
following though there'd be many
variations on this crazy idea by far the
one who came the closest and strangest
and comedy was the one on Fox kids
that's cool but can I have a show based
on my book series where the scariest
part was the covered no oh but you can
have a show that's less scary than are
you afraid the dark goosebumps was based
on the hugely successful book series by
RL Stine
it was wild imaginative and not the
least bit scary you know I'm right you
know I'm right when I was younger I was
always pissed off that all the scary
shows i watch were never scary
goosebumps are you afraid of the dark
even Tales from the Crypt I never found
frightening but as I got older I
realized that's not really what they
were about the intent wasn't to scare
you the intent was to have fun in a
classically spooky setup one of these
episodes is about a killer sponge for
God's sake the Hokie acting and
over-the-top writing only add to the
b-movie quality that honestly kind it
gets better every time I see it
that doesn't mean they weren't trying it
just means it should be enjoyed on a
different level than you might expect
it's like getting angry if a scooby-doo
episode isn't scary it's just not what
you're supposed to be looking for every
show I had a new monster or a new
scenario that would tie into the
characters persona or fears similar to
The Twilight Zone
except you know laughably stupid it took
me a while to warm up to this series but
now
watching it with the intent of having a
good time that's exactly what I get out
of it a good time it's one of those
kooky kid shows I've weirdly enough like
even more as an adult than I do as a kid
just for entirely different reasons
[Music]
sadly though this is when Fox kids began
their downward spiral how long did they
last after that just a mere six years
that's stupid long I know but here's the
thing Warner Brothers was starting their
own network with their own kids
programming called Kids WB and when they
started up guess what they took with
them
Animaniacs Looney Tunes and Batman they
even did spin-off shows like Superman
pinky in the brain and their own little
Japanese import that was dirt cheap to
make and would run for years and years
in fact even the first Animaniacs
episode on Kids WB was a parody of Fox's
biggest show Power Rangers hey what's
wrong with your mouth it's all fuzzy Fox
would still do well but this was a big
bite for them and many of the upcoming
shows did well but not nearly as well as
before another feel book show called
toon sylvania try capturing a darker
tone on the Animaniacs formula but sadly
the writing wasn't unplaned and it
didn't last very long I talked in great
detail about Sam and Max in another
episode it was creative but a little too
unfocused earning only one season and
then of course there's this that's like
summing up the Titanic in one sense I
need a full episode to go into what's
wrong with that yeah good cause after
that five kids went the same route kiss
WB went importing more and more Japanese
shows after seeing not only how easier
they are to put out but also how cheap
they are to do and sadly I stopped
watching after that if we were gonna go
into this in more detail we would need
people that actually grew up watching
this
[Music]
okay go ahead hey kids remember this
incredible writing that's a lot of fish
they made a show out of it oh gosh
Godzilla the series was a direct
continuation of the 1998 Godzilla movie
it featured some actors from the film
lending their voices to reprise their
roles including Bart Simpson Shh
thankfully Matthew Broderick wasn't one
of them but his character Oh what Nick
Nick Tatopoulos Tatopoulos two table
sits atop Alicia it's Greek ha ha ha
did return the only surviving offspring
of the Godzilla that attacked New York
and the movie imprinted onto Nick as its
parent and thus they used him as a
government-sponsored Pokemon to fight
other giant monsters that's so stupid
I'm surprised it wasn't in the 98 film
so am i this series was received pretty
well by fans of Godzilla but honestly
following the 98 film there was nowhere
to go but up we did get some great kaiju
fights in the show though so I guess I
can look past Godzilla's Dick Tracy chin
I guess it's better than a of the Power
Rangers and then there's Power Rangers
in space and lost galaxies
Power Rangers in space wrapped up the
show's initial run and was supposed to
be the series finale as we know that
didn't happen
much to our Vikrant
what on the surface steam like Star Trek
light actually became one the most
popular and well-received seasons in the
show's history they went much further
with character development than they did
in most of the previous seasons there
were decently deep arcs for a kids show
that featured the red Rangers long-lost
sister being brainwashed as the Power
Rangers main enemy and even more
multi-dimensional villains there's
plenty more to talk about with this
season which finished the Zordon era and
ended up saving the franchise but some
of you may just know what further
crossover with the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles cowabunga and I guess hey we
ever deal known expectation unless he's
fully being tortured it's okay just a
mention of the idea hurt sufficiently
the next season Power Rangers lost
galaxy kept the outer space theme but
began a new phase in the PR legacy
starting here every season introduced a
new cast that new power swords etc and
that became the status quo for the
series moving forward Saban's big plan
to get this phase going sword in the
stone in space woo
actually this season was pretty good I
enjoyed quite a bit but I know what
you're thinking those shows needed a lot
more Ryan Gosling as young Hercules it's
actually amazing how much we weren't
thinking that well Fox Kids was I was
thinking that
[Music]
yep there was a spinoff of the Kevin
Sorbo show starring a young Ryan Gosling
I always speculated this was just
another goosebumps episode he was in it
is scary enough what else do you need to
know about this show well I think this
clip says it all
what is a performance that you've given
something that you're insanely product
might work on you and Hercules really I
had a fake tan leather pants was
fighting imaginary monsters they weren't
really there but I was acting like they
were there my god I think we're all in a
goosebumps episode we also can't forget
about Beast Wars this is one of my
favorite childhood shows it traded in
cool cars trucks and jets for animals
like rats and ants
[Music]
believe me it's way cooler than it
sounds this was my generation's
transformer show and I absolutely loved
Beast Wars along with reboot was among
the first all CG animated series the
early computerized look doesn't hold up
all that well but for the time it was
revolutionary and set the show apart
from most other things on TV the stories
were great the characters were great it
was just a really solid animated series
that being said you stay away from this
Michael Bay you hear me don't you dare
defile rat traps like a dragger Optimus
Prime or in this series you can check
out my top 5 best episodes right here on
the channel if my face isn't on it I
don't watch it like I haven't heard that
before Beast Machines transformers was
the less popular sequel series to Beast
Wars it took place almost immediately
after and was dark sobering and kind of
depressing at times you know for the
kids the change in tone and design
wasn't something anyone was asking for
but it did end all the stories that
started in Beast Wars and has gained a
small dedicated following over the years
blah blah blah akin to the more hardcore
stuff oh you mean like Frank Miller yeah
there was a show based on a Frank Miller
comic
[Music]
big guy in rusty the boy robot was a
show based on a short comic written by
Frank Miller there really isn't too much
crossover between the show and the comic
with the show actually being more
fleshed out than the comic hey samuel
l.jackson in it not know rusty is the
most advanced robot ever made with a
complicated AI and ability to feel
emotions he was meant to be the
successor to big guy an advanced robot
that protects earth however Rusty's
emotional circuits and AI are young and
he therefore acts like a child rusty
needs to learn how to be the protector
of Earth the guy is reka mission so he
can teach rusty the guy in rusty was one
of the more complex and mature shows in
the year ten lineup it was pretty
interesting and unique although it was
never my favorite show I do remember
being engaged by it and wanting to see
what happened next
[Music]
oh good to know not everything was a
Japanese import and then there was
Digimon when Pokemon became a smash hit
Fox kids try to capitalize on that
market and trend by introducing the
world of Digimon seven kids at a summer
camp are transported to a digital world
creatively called the digi world there
they discover they are the digidestined
who must help save the digital and real
worlds with the help of their partner
digital monsters or Digimon they are
also given digi devices which transport
them between the real and digital worlds
and can help their Digimon Digimon to
other forms sake DG again I dare you I
double dare ya digi melon mad the show
was actually a lot of fun although it
never reached the fever pitch of Pokemon
it was received well by audiences
although there was fan demand that the
anime be shown in its entirety as the
Fox Kids version was edited and changed
to fit a more humorous tone than the
original Japanese show and who could
ever forget that
theme song my head and you put it right
back in there oh I thought you're still
humming ducktales because of Digimon
success we also got monster rancher
another monster show that was meant to
compete with the success of Pokemon
master rancher was first a video game
before being made into an anime that Fox
kids picked up in the game you used
discs to unlock monsters that the player
trains to compete in tournaments in the
show a boy named Genki receives a disc
to use while playing the disc ends up
transporting him to a different world
where the monsters are real and created
by scanning stone discs and temples like
Digimon monster rancher was edited to
make it more suitable for audiences
removing more dramatic elements from the
series I remember loving the show as a
kid but honestly it was a bit bland and
basically an over glorified commercial
so an anime oh Christ I hit a nerve
Fox did give spider-man another go with
spider-man unlimited a loose equal to
the 94 series while having a strange and
somewhat confusing plot that sends
spider-man to a duplicate world on the
far side of the Sun called counter-earth
normally this would be like a parallel
dimension or something but apparently
that's not exactly what unlimited was
going for instead we got a really weird
futuristic planet for spider-man to
fight venom and carnage on while freeing
humans from oppression wow this is
making his deal with the devil almost
sound credible due to legal issues this
series couldn't draw from any of the
decades of source material that came
before it or even used the standard
spider-man suit for most of its run
there have been some awesome designs for
alternate Spider suits made over the
years but a web cape unique to say the
least the opening theme sounds like it's
trying to be Batman Beyond but comes off
like it's goofy clubbing cousin like
loving a seal I think you mean I get
that spider-man the animated series is
an insanely tough act to follow but
spider-man unlimited was a mess from the
beginning both behind and on the screen
that his best skipped over by fans of
the webhead
and then there's Angela anaconda did and
he was actually watched this show oh I
can see why by year 12 Fox Kids was
losing momentum and pulled back weekday
scheduling - only Saturday mornings by
then the writing must have been on the
wall because the following year Fox kids
stopped airing programs and never
returned
though many of these shows would exist
in reruns and there's more than enough
kid shows everywhere now that magic
collection of the right talent for the
right age group at the right time never
seemed as prominent
every Saturday morning built an
anticipation like no other every visit
home from school revved up excitement
every kid could feel for a pretty
awesome time in our childhoods we had a
cool clubhouse that lived in our TV and
they told us great jokes classic stories
the latest comics and even taught us a
thing or two it was everything you
thought of when you heard the word
Saturday morning it was a perfect
experience so much of us were so happy
to have and we couldn't be more thankful
to the awesome people who gave us some
absolutely wonderful Saturday mornings
on Fox kids speaking of which we should
probably start getting ready for bed
what oh yeah I guess we have been
watching willow for 12 hours of shows so
what do we do now
well protocol says we should be playing
video games past our bedtime laugh and
scream at basically nothing and have
deep philosophical talks while trying to
go to sleep sounds good hmm do you
believe in God believe or see
you see God well yeah I was thinking
about that and it had me thinking what
if bowser's the good guy you know and
Mario is really the bad guy okay but is
then if Satan why luigi no no that's
just not true that's a dirty lie well if
Mario is the bad guy then luigi is
saying oh well it was how do we go from
God to Bowser I missed that video games
are our God
okay my religion actually thanks yeah so
like video games equal God it's all
different you know denominations respect
like Tamra believes in the denomination
of Playstation but like Walter and I are
Nintendo i'ts so yeah like come to be
awkward sometimes I have a Playstation
like don't don't tell Nintendo but I
like I have a Playstation because like
sometimes just get explore things man
yeah you gotta do stuff well while
you're young you know what I mean I
think I'm an atheist cuz I have a
Dreamcast no they started with the
Dreamcast man it's fine yeah
everything's gonna be okay so I don't
know man I don't think my mom's gonna
let me sleep over here anymore
hi Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing build
Chicago build grows hope and engagement
with a wide array of school and
community based programs that build the
habits of success spark interests
uncover talents give kids a sense of
accomplishment and empower them with the
tools to resist risky behavior and make
positive choices their mission is to
engage at-risk youth in schools and on
the streets so they can realize their
educational and career potential and
contribute to the stability safety and
well-being of our communities founded in
1969 as a pioneering gang intervention
program build is nationally recognized
as a gang intervention violence
prevention and youth development
impacting over 3,000 youth and families
in five Chicago's most challenged
communities built holistic model
integrates an array of services to meet
individual and community needs including
gang intervention violence prevention
college and career readiness youth
leadership development and civic
engagement entrepreneurship the arts and
clinical services their objective is to
ensure that every child has a bright
future regardless of individual
challenges or neighborhood barriers if
you look at their site on their YouTube
page you can see all the creative ways
they help kids find a future where they
can thrive and succeed they have tons of
events you can visit donate to or
volunteer at on their site and like I
said they got that great peace parade
and carnival coming up in August so you
should definitely show up there if you
can click on the link and see how you
can play a big part in keeping the
future peaceful and strong
[Music]
you